Here's the alternating
trick in some more detail.
Suppose that M1 recognizes L and
M2 recognizes L complement.
We want to decide the language L.
In pseudo code the alternating
strategy might look like this.
In every iteration we
execute both machines,
one more step than we did the last time.
Note that it doesn't matter if we
save the machines' configuration and
start where we left off, or start over.
The question is whether we get
the right answer, not how fast.
The string has to either be an L,
or an L complement.
So one of these has to halt after
some finite number of steps.
And when i hits that value this
program will give the right answer.
Overall then we have
the following theorem.
A language L is decidable if and only if
L and its compliment are recognizable.